on n'apprend pas véritablement aux
jeunes les clés de compréhension de leur
sexualité et de leur fonctionnement
donc le souci c'est pas la pornographie
c'est qu'ils rien en face et donc
culpabiliser les personnes qui portent
un croc top c'est en aucun cas une
éducation pour moi c'est une pub
habilitation supplémentaire et c'est une
excuse donné aux hommes pour leurs
regards et leurs pulsions au moins
l'éducation elle doit être surtout du
côté des hommes on appelle quittant les
femmes à se protéger à être vigilante à
faire attention mais on dit jamais aux
hommes mais ne viole pas et en fait
c'est aussi simple que ça quelque part
c'est qu' il faut une fin de cette
impunité
il faut une fin de cette logique que
nous serions de responsables des
agressions que nous subissons et parce
que c'était tout simplement pas normal
s'il ya seulement 1% des violeurs qui
sont condamnés en france aujourd'hui
c'est parce qu'on est purement dans
cette logique là que quelque part quand
on subit un violent on a forcément une
part de responsabilité c'est soit notre
tenue soit qu'on était à un endroit on
devrait pas être ce qu'on avait pris de
l'alcool ou des substances qu'on
n'aurait pas dû prendre et donc on va
pour les femmes
dire que le consentement passe par tous
ces critères là alors que pour un homme
le consentement passe par un oui
simplement
donc le fait qu'ils aient un peu ce
double traitement qu'on exige des femmes
une exemplarité justement enfin au
niveau de la tenue où il faut être dans
un entre deux c'est pas normal et c'est
à cause du regard masculin qu'on n'est
dupe a entre autre combat imposé sa au
corps des femmes
si un homme peut porter un short est pas
une femme c'est pas parce qu'il ya une
différence biologique
c'est tout simplement parce qu'on a
sexualisé les gens des femmes qui
peuvent être totalement similaire des
jambes des hommes dans les
caractéristiques sexuels secondaires
il ya les poils aussi par exemple les
femmes auront ça fait partie de leurs
caractéristiques sexuels secondaires
sont que dans le phénomène de
sexualisation on a dit aux femmes qu'il
fallait supprimer ces points donc c'est
pas de la biologie c'est purement la
construction sociale il faut questionner
ça et si on ne sexualise pas justement
ce corps des hommes
c'est parce qu'on autorise en fait les
hommes à avoir un corps les femmes n'ont
pas le droit de faire corps aussi bien
dans l'espace public que dans la société
de manière générale on efface les corps
des femmes sauf quand ils sont mises en
scène une par exemple dans la publicité
où là on va accepter parce que ces
décors esthétisé et qui sont passés
derrière le regard des hommes
si on choisit d'être maîtresse de nos
propres records de le posséder
véritablement est en fait d'en être
actrice
là tout d'un coup il ya une sanction
c'est ça la véritable liberté c'est de
choisir de porter aussi bien un short
qu'un voile de faire absolument ce qu'on
veut sauf que quand il prend cette
liberté là on nous renvoie
systématiquement cette sanction
patriarcale
non il n'a pas le droit de faire ce
qu'on veut de son corps et le corps des
femmes ne nous appartient pas il
appartient aux lois il appartient à
l'état
il appartient aux hommes
[Musique]